hi guys I got a question about nuts and
seeds on a ketogenic diet they're
totally okay to do but let me just kind
of cover some points about it
pecans are really fatty and those are
real good nut to consume on this eating
plan macadamia nuts are even better
because they're more fat the thing is
about macadamia nuts so sometimes they
go rancid so you have to make sure that
you get them fresh walnuts too can go
rancid make sure that the fresh not the
ones that you buy in the bin that sit
there for like six months cashews are a
bit high in carbohydrate so if you're
going to consume those do smaller
amounts but they're very sweet and
they're very easy and addictive to keep
eating especially around the holidays
the problem is keeping them in bowls
around your house everywhere you go at
night you're like tempted or watching
other people eating them it's like not
good
I had a person's just recently made a
comment I thought it was kind of funny
they said it's not about watching your
diets but watching other people's diet
it's like wow that's just ten ten things
okay let's talk about the nut butters
like peanut butter make sure on the
label it does not have added sugar
hydrogenated oils
you just want sea salt and peanuts
that's it or sea salt and almonds that's
it because they put so much other stuff
in there and you want to make sure that
the actual penis doesn't have added
monosodium glutamate or modified food
starts they add that in there to make
the peanuts or the mixed nuts tastes
better I'm going to recommend you
because it's really easy to overdo nuts
and irritate the gall bladder especially
if the nut is raw because it has phytic
acid which tends to irritate the gall
bladder and cause right shoulder pain
two to three ounces in a given meal
that's what you want to stick with
trying to go more than that especially
if you have a gallbladder issue and then
we have the seeds seeds are high in
nutrients high in healthy fats low in
carb seeds are actually even better than
the nuts
stars nutrient wise you have the
sunflower seeds the hemp seeds chia
seeds flax seeds you can make crackers
with them we're going to put our recipe
on cracker
you can put them on salads you can make
a trail mix there's so many different
ways you can even there's even a recipe
you can make a kind of a rice out of
hemp but anyway these are okay these are
the guidelines and put your comments
below hi guys hey listen I created a
pretty amazing evaluation quiz down
below that actually analyzes your
symptoms to find the cause the root
cause of all of your symptoms the most
likely cause
so take the quiz now and we'll send you
report